i have somebody who would love to meet
you i think you'll be happy to meet her
i don't know
you tell me
[Music]
he painted for many including the
greatest muhammad ali
but after falling on hard times richard
hutchins found himself
homeless that is until recently when he
met a man called
charlie rocket and now richard the
artist is being
discovered all over again and both men
join me right now
hey guys five days ago i was homeless
never again i didn't do i didn't i
didn't give up my dream
i didn't lose hope my spirit wasn't
broken
the gallery show the sales online
the billboard the flowers you're getting
from people
all over the world how are you feeling
in this moment
what is this like for you there's no
words for that
i'm just blessed and i'm very humble
when i look at the computer and i see
all these millions of people
sending out they love it and respecting
me and all these people find my work
mr steve harvey two chains
there's no words for it i'm just hungry
he said three thousand dollars got him
out of homelessness
dad at the apollo theater so he wanted
to pay three thousand dollars for a
painting
charlie take us back to earlier this
year when
you met richard how did you know this
was a story and a talent that
needed to be shared it was easter sunday
we pulled up to the ralph's and this
this guy sitting on the corner on a
shopping cart said
let's go let me try that car tonight
i was like i told my friend i like him
so we went grocery shopping when we came
out
we both gave richard hundred dollars he
started crying richard's a crowd
i'm very soft he even asked us for help
he told us his dream and that's like the
best thing a human being could ever say
we were like you know what maybe we can
help you a little bit and the next day
we took him shopping to the art store
he spent two thousand dollars on a man
that he only known for two days my dream
is it
just walk in the museum one day and just
see my sitter with my penguin on the
wall
i've seen some of the work that you did
while you were incarcerated
i saw a video where you shared that you
used to use skittles
to paint while i was in my cell 23 hours
a day
i found myself alone and wanted to do
something so i started writing my
friends i would look at these envelopes
they looked dead so i started drawing on
them and i had gotten skittles and m m's
and i seen them sitting there and i'm
saying to myself
let me try this and i use those things i
had a long beard i would take care of my
off my beard and i would take a string
wrap around to make a paintbrush to get
the little fine details up here that's
how you can see when you look at my work
you can see little fine lines and stuff
in it
i used frames of hair from my beard to
do that a lot of people didn't know that
and i started sending them out in the in
the deputies used to race right now to
get the umbrellas to take them out
and let them see what was next i did
over 150 of them
one of the uh staff members saw how i
saw my work i had a book out
and they saw that book and they came and
got me and i began to paint these
gigantic beautiful murals inside inside
the gel fantastic
i have somebody who would love to meet
you who
honestly has been so inspired and so
excited by all that you've been doing
and i think just like the rest of the
world has
i think you'll be happy to meet her i
don't know you tell me
hey
hey richard how old are you
you know what i did some years ago i
drew a picture of you and your father
oh wow your father would you hold the
emmy
yeah years ago in texas yeah
yeah yeah throw that picture over
someone stole that picture
someone's stole it
well it's it's just my pleasure to meet
you tondo is my beautiful daughter girl
and she was telling me that she was
going to be doing this story on you and
i saw some of your beautiful art and
i said well i have to get one of those
paintings
actually i think richard you're not
charging enough money
you're not charging enough for these
paintings you know what we just went
through i don't even know how
i almost gave this stuff away because i
i i don't know how to even to be
to begin to price it so i saw something
like it's like an angela davis portrait
it was like 150.
so i mean listen i'm gonna pay 1500 for
that because she needs to be at least
10 times what what you're asking for
okay
just like i told her mrs winfrey it's my
job to help
i'm so proud of you taking your pain and
turning it into promise
and really moving that promise into a
powerful
form of expression for yourself because
what i know
for sure is that that's what all of us
as human beings are looking for
we all just want to be able to have the
truest highest expression of ourselves
and you are doing that and
i just want to encourage you to keep
doing it i'm also going to buy that
flower girl too so i'm going to pay 2500
for her
we have the original original okay well
i want to buy her too
yes ma'am hey bring that over here
somebody bring me that please
you have the original flower girl oh wow
oh no oh wow
so what are you selling the original for
i don't know this
these guys here that's their job i have
no idea
i'm going to offer you 5 000 for her
it's yours
god bless you thank you miss winfrey
thank you so much ma'am